uh full council meeting
i don't think any members of the public
here but i'd like to welcome anyone
that's tuning in on youtube
um
the benefit of members we're not
expecting any fire alarms tonight so if
an alarm goes saying please follow the
directions that the officers will give
and evacuate
okay we'll get into the agenda proper
the first item is apologies for absence
yes chair we've got apologies from
cancer rock councillor brown councillor
watson councillor hackett councillor
pennington and councillor branton
item two uh is the full casual minutes
of the first of november
which i'll go through page one page
starts on page five
chair
let's afford
because i'm about to put knox emotion in
i think it'd be better because i cannot
accept minutes and i'd like for two
minutes to be able to explain why
and it does tie up in the numbers i've
got later in the new team
well if you can be very briefer that
means well
grief is all right uh chair but it's
very being factual
okay and i will be as brief as i can and
i will try to be as tight as i can but
something that's very important
so i will not agree to sign off
at this time
i spoke to a most helpful member of
staff who had agreed to check some of
missions i had alluded to
she was prepared to
minutes to include celebrations as a
mission can be as important as an
incorrect inclusion
i thanked her and stressed i did not
wish niche to be verbatim i do know
latin
a question therefore why the head of
legal did not
want the ministry to be accurate
the missions are required were and is
relevant because the serious things that
um this could be public and people might
be listed for this okay
now i'm aware of that okay
i did mention when we have the
superintendent here which is very useful
informatively for many members about an
ilpc campaign a friends and family
policy but most importantly he had his
topic
he got in
he said state is a bit of a police
station and the identification of
officers and that i was ahead of the
game as i had to ask the entire cip
officer on the 30th of march
if a certain pc was for real which is on
my phone if anybody wishes to see it
okay
emissions are very important should a
legal challenge be made
this seems to be a trait of this council
of the porno at the standard hearing
involving evidence
cropped chains against abuse against
myself and therefore presidential to
repair eerie
i would also stay
and ask the superintendent if he could
assure me that if members of the public
especially vulnerable
women reference the ever case which i
alluded to
who questioned the identification of an
officer they would be treated with
respecting courtesy however
i just have throughs insurance for it
okay however to my dismay a recent
example of a female officer at
bostonville
being treated disgracefully by a male
colleague she has awarded ten thousand
pain all this has been reported okay
does not fill me with confidence thank
you chair
i've got the copy of the um design
please do a great job
and i've got a copy of the hard
copy be ladies need it for a minute
thank you
i can cancel four
so
on page six
page seven
eight
age nine
page ten
ages eleven
12
13
14
15
and 16
17
and 18.
i'll propose them from the chair i've
got a seconder
that's your inch
i'll show off hands all in favor please
[Music]
and that is no disrespect of the
that was 28 4 and one against chair are
there any extensions
thank you
item three on the agenda is the action
list which is
page 18.
um
pennington's not chair tonight but um
the item 252
on your agenda shows that it's ongoing
we received email from councillor
pennington earlier today so that will be
circulated um shortly
so that's
agreement of uh agenda items part one
and two there are part two items so i'll
propose from the chair that we
one second of this
comes with james all in favor
item seven let's consider correspondence
and the other business brought forward
by the direction of the chair i've only
got a couple of um
small things there is a christmas raffle
going for members of staff in the robot
house um
i forgotten all about it myself i just
made a contribution towards that so i
would encourage members who wish to
contribute to
be given to culture hudson or drop in
the riverbank house or find some other
way of dropping in your
thank you very much thank you the other
item i'd just like to take an
opportunity
uh under this item to thank all of our
members of staff you know the frontline
staff
the office staff the refuge collection
uh staff they've done a tremendous
job of work i think this year in very
difficult circumstances
cool with restrictions
back into work and
all working again so i'd just like to
pass on
all of our thanks to all members of
staff
i'm sure we all like all right
thank you very much
okay moving on to item eight to answer a
question submitted under procedural rule
a9
there are two questions submitted one
from casey ford
um uncompressed with christie
yeah
what i would like for the benefit of
transparency and democracy and the fact
that one of two people that probably
more than i am might be watching this
um
should the question i suppose would be
written
relevant so if a member
i'll read it as i'm in the chair so
pencil ford's written question
is is the council aware of the concept
of woeful blindness
can the clarify and clarity be given on
the definition of willful blindness
should senior public servants be guilty
of this they could have serious
consequences
and the answer of giving by the officer
is that this is a question directed
council not to the staff which comprises
the 31 elected members therefore
officers have not at this stage prepared
an answer
so
as the most of
the
actual letter the procedural letter is
the council aware so it's not it's the
office or the offices of theirs
is the council i think that's us for 36
members
are we aware of willful blindness
i must on the side speaking firsthand
it's the first time i've ever seen that
phrase use willful blindness i i'm not
aware of the of that phrase myself
um
well anyone else has any comments on i
mean i would i would just say
um
clearly there this is this is an issue
which has been running on for some time
um willful blindness as i said i'm not
aware of that myself
um
willful willful a timeless thing i am
aware of
i would suggest that possibly uh this
may be a um i would suggest this is a
good example of that so unless you've
got anything to add to that yeah
we'll uh we'll move on but i mean
[Music]
consequences and it is relevant to
council businesses
there are several national food can i
just remind you i'm sure you're aware of
the rules we are allowed to ask
supplementary
question it will be kind of not not not
a statement so you know as i said
briefly
is this another example whereby you
don't want me to say anything no i'll
just say you can you can ask a second
question what you've just told me from
the chair that you
were unaware of this title is unaware of
the concept of world war blindness is
that correct
i said i personally am not allowed
all right
but basically what i would suggest to
you
is yes it has significance and i can
prove that some councillors from
officers are guilty of that and in the
process that will happen
okay
what i will say is to just keep this
jovial at this stage
angry
but up to now i don't think
and then unless you're [ __ ] what
opera tommy
then
i don't know whether there's anything
called willful deafness but basically
this has got serious consequences
and actually the fact that this council
is actually unaware
of that and going back to buying or any
frost we've got rules we have got to
conduct sadly we don't adhere to them
right
there wasn't any rules in the
changing room for pure o'brien but i'll
tell you what she's good with devin
stockton so am i thanks sharon
thank you council ford
and the other
yes the other
question was from country christie on
the procedure rule 9.
sorry
questions aren't allowed at the stage
okay
this is country christie's uh submission
submit submission under procedural rule
nine uh it's two parts have quotes and
sought for the work needed to spread
from the riverbank wall at bronze with
dwarf and if so what are they
and b in the event that the recently won
government grant is not enough to cover
the work who will pay the additional
cost
there is a two-part answer which i'll
give
first of all
members will be aware that this area of
work is the responsibility of the
developer right earth therefore
counselor chrissy
could if he wished
a director's question to the developer
the second answer is that again is a
matter for the developer to consider as
a council has no requirement to cover
any additional cost should they arise
that's the best
well
i think the second answer is the most
interesting actually
um now i've raised this because
it's all very well saying the developer
seems quite something but the river wall
and the uh
walkway on top revert to torridge after
it's been done we will be responsible
for that war and i think we need to keep
an eye on it
because of that
um i've got a question
what happens this is why i've asked
about the quotes what happens if the
quote comes in
under 800 thousand we don't know nobody
seems to know
does the money come back
to torridge and we have to give it back
to the government for what
thank you
797 000 pounds from the land release
fund um should the works come in at a
notion of 500 000 that's all that we
wish all day
so there wouldn't be a balance
without with the council and it wouldn't
go to the double
so sorry so we haven't actually given
the money yet yeah
so we will see the quotes
we'll have to
we'll agree the specification
yes and then we will agree what work
will be done and we'll agree to pay up
to 797 000 pounds to assist him
should it cost more than that balance is
his should it cost less than that he'll
provide us with the evidence we'll claim
and we'll only draw down what he spent
so i can ask this question again later
and see how much it costs thank you
moving on into item nine which is the
mid-year review of treasury management
ages
19-27 on your agenda and i think we're
gonna handle david haynes
thank you it's a long agenda and a dry
report so i won't keep you any longer
than an sv on this one
and the city code of treasury management
requires that we do a mid-year review of
our treasury management
and the key points are we undertook new
normally borrowing during the year
we've got 661k of outstanding debt with
the public works loan board
short-term investments this is fixed
term fixed fixed rate short-term
investments down to 23 million at the
same time last year 17 million
the bank of england base rates currently
0.1
that's why we're not getting very much
in return on our investments our
short-term investments
since the global pandemic we've actually
disputed over nearly 60 56 million
pounds worth of grants
because of the amount of money that's
going through the council's bank account
because of the distribution of grants
and uncertainty of when um the
government will reclaim unspent grants
that's why we've got quite a lot of cash
flow we've been perfectly honest so i
just want the members to note there that
we've actually exceeded our counterparty
limit which is uh five million with our
current bank which is lloyd to be honest
there isn't very much we can do about it
the government deposit 30 million pounds
in our bank account and don't tell us
when they want the balance back
essentially
and so the recommendations are to note
the mid-year treasury management review
and also to note the technical breach of
our counterparty limit with lloyd's bank
and it's just been noted
any questions
council homes
the difficulty is when they don't need
to offer it for instant access council
homes so we don't know when the
government's going to say well okay
we gave you 30 million spent 23 7
million back we have very short notice
period as to when they want that money
back so at the moment we find it
difficult to find a green investment
where it's instant access that's our
dilemma
i think you know somewhere else that
councils can invest in other local
authorities is that right
we could but learn when we talk about
the difficulty we have and i get
is the uncertainty of how long we can
put the money out for
we're in a very artificial position at
the moment about without cash that's
actually circulating through the banks
and the capitals bank accounts primarily
because of the legacy of the colby
business support grants now we've
touched we're coming towards the end of
that process and get back more and even
cure where we can actually do some
proper cash flow forecasting
as lead member for finance i'd like to
move that we note both these
recommendations
the first one that we note the midterm
treasury management review and the
second one that we acknowledge the
breach of the counterparty limit
so i suggest we all agree to note
those recommendations thank you that's
all you're doing is nothing there's no
vote on this so um
that's that no other questions thank you
david i'm going to stay here
for the next one
item 10 is potential tax base for 22-23
which is pages 28-31 on the agenda again
david is going to take this one yeah
again hopefully short and sweet um
as the billing authority we're
obliged to set a tax base by the 31st of
january
um setting the tax base is vitally
important to our preceptors double
county council the fire the police force
in our town and parish councils
and essentially what we do is we take a
snapshot of properties rechargeable for
council tax at the 30th of november and
then we adjust it looking like branding
appeals over release so for example
if you live on your own you get a 25
discount single person discount we also
adjusted for the number of claims for
local council tax support and we make an
estimate of new properties that are
going to come on stream during the
course of the year the rate of this year
and for the next financial year and then
also we make a judgment call on what the
collection rate will be
so simply put it we calculate that the
tax base will be twenty four thousand
four hundred and forty seven point zero
three band d equivalents so it's roughly
about thirty two thousand properties
and that's an increase over the previous
year of one point seven percent on the
um slide that's hopefully behind my head
you'll see that we increased properties
account for 0.7 percent of that
um a decline in the number of people
claiming council tax support accounts
for 0.5 and the collection rate
increasing the cash account for 0.5
so it is a recommendation it doesn't
need to be approved by full council so
the recommendation is that council agree
the tax base for
2022-23 at 24
forty seven point zero four
coach holden i'd like to move the
recommendation chairman
members accept the tax base
second lecture sorry council manny had
her hand up
okay
proportions sorry question yeah don't
just ask a question uh keep
bearing in mind what happened
over the last couple years with the
police especially
have
so you talk about the increases on
council tax yeah
um the police i believe it's 10 pound
per band equivalent
got to set so the police authority could
raise a van d council tax by up to 10
pounds
but they haven't set to make that
decision
and um the
county i think it's two percent plus one
percent for adult social care precepts
again they haven't met i think the fire
authorities two percent in town and
parish councils again have no limits
okay there's there are no other
questions we've been proposing secondly
can i sure fans in favor please
[Music]
would you like to just read those
outside of this yes chad that's 28 four
and one upstairs abstention thank you
very much
okay moving on
the organization of country tax support
which is pages
32-47
and stacy is going to take this one for
us
thank you chair
um
as members will know it's for each
council to um effectively design their
own council tax support scheme um set
out within the framework of the
legislation
um today i'm going to ask for members
permission to roll over our current
scheme
um for a very very good reason
i'm not usually one to um talk about the
amount of work that that teams have but
on this occasion
um i don't think it can go without
saying
the amount of additional work that the
revenue and benefits team have had this
year um predominantly due to covered
and just to give members a taste um
they've paid out 51 million
in business support grants
in addition they've had the test and
trace payment scheme
they've paid out 198 000 um with that
and that's a scheme that's still ongoing
as members will know
they've had the
hardship support fund
and more recently the household support
fund
um
in addition um there's been an increase
in uh people applying for universal
credit
um and changes to the universal credit
which again
all affects the benefits system
and means that they have to manually
update and assess claims that are coming
through
um so with the best will in the world
um
they just haven't had the capability to
review the current scheme as it stands
um
and
what we're hopefully um
going to do is review it for the next
financial year so if it can roll over 22
23
um plans are already in place um to
start the review for next year the
working group has been reformed as a
meeting in january
um
and some provisional assessments are
going to be are being undertaken but
when it last came before full council um
members agreed that it could be rolled
over and reviewed um with a view to
looking at it if we have the resources
and i hope members can agree tonight um
with the actual extra work they have had
on top of them
and to be fair that is still continuing
just hasn't been been possible
um so i'm asking for it to be rolled
over for 22 23
resources permitting again
thank you that seems eminently sensible
to me i'll move from the chair that we
do that do you have a second pencil
newton all in favor please sure
thank you chandra
okay item 12 uh on your agenda is the
gross maintenance
the capital for that pages 48-49
i'm the finance manager david hayes is
[Music]
okay hopefully another short and sweet
report i can't give any comments about
what the item in part two
as members are aware the decision was
made to bring our grounds maintenance um
operation in-house and with offices have
been visibly working a way to make this
happen effectively the first of april
2022
in a normal course of events our capital
program is
approved by full council in february
however in order to be operational on
the 1st of april 2022 the council needs
to purchase various items of capital
nature in order to have a functioning
service on the 1st of april so therefore
we need to add to the existing capital
programme during the course of the
financial year and that's essentially
what the report is
asking for member approval on
i wasn't planning on saying anymore
anybody's got any questions before we
move the recommendation
council haynes
um yeah
the
of
67 thousands of transit vans and
trailers um this is obviously not enough
to fix this electric vehicles
um which is disappointing but i have
investigated
richard haste who tells me that
um
heavy-duty vehicles are needed to pull
trailers and electric vehicles aren't
suitable
i hope that
this situation will i'm sure will still
be
looked at and as time goes on and it's
disappointing
um also disappointing is under climate
change
over the course of the next few years
the council
may seek to align his friends against
operations
um i find that so use the word may while
disappointing
and then the second paragraph
um
yes attention
yeah that's
looking for a mix of textual electric
battery power questions um it's good
that
we're doing that but again i feel that
there should be a stronger statement
i was going to propose
adding to the recommendations
that under climate change in the report
the wording will be changed in the first
paragraph
to the council will
seek
yeah
will seem to align its grounds
maintenance operations only in line with
approved carbon training instead of the
word lay
and then the second
where possible give priority a priority
to using electric battery powered handle
equipment
in other words
i would like to see a much stronger
commitment really which will start
with i'll try much more without
them
separate
separate paragraphs which would go on
recommendations
well i
i can
see exactly where you're coming from
with this and council haims and you know
i share your sentiment i think up to a
point but clearly
the equipment that the brand's
maintenance are going to use it needs to
be you know fit for purpose and assuming
where they can use
electrically operated or battery
operated um equipment you know such as
tools and equipment and the small bits
of equipment clearly that's what they
would do
first thing they're really really good
if you can use that you haven't got a
bother of mains leads but on the other
hand there are some bits of equipment
that at the moment just aren't suitable
for um from you know battery use so
there will still be a requirement for
some time but um i may come back but
it's not an absolute i've used the words
will seek to yeah and where possible
give priorities so you know it's not
absolutely okay
well it's been proposed if you've got a
second for that reason
that's a problem honking yeah
it doesn't no not in any significant way
special laws
we are a committed council
all this is asking for is in the future
yeah absolutely
excellent
okay it's been proposed and second dick
have a show of handsome thank you
sorry i can't really question i didn't
see that yeah can i ask the question um
council remain realize that uh when a
cemetery is closed torridge have to take
it over
and one of the largest centuries
we may have well we will have to take
over is eastern water and biddeford but
i understood there was some dispute
there have we taken that over or not yet
i'm seeing adrian redwood nodding
so i assume that's really affirmative
right okay it's been proposed and
secondly we have show off hands in favor
of council rehabilitation and obviously
what's before you know
all right okay so we know we need a
proposal and a second of the actual
report before you pop a post on the
chair
um can we do that again please because
we didn't record the abstentions so all
in favor of country haynes's
amendment
and again
one
two against
and any uh abstentions
one abstention
you have to read those samples yes share
the vote is 26 for
two against and one abstention thank you
okay then we need to vote on the actual
uh
recommendation which is what you just
discussed so i'll report on the chair we
do that
that's right second did that all in
favor please sure
that's your name
thank you very much
okay item 13 on your agenda is active
courage the strategic aims which is age
50 and 52
and i believe you're going to do this
thank you
uh thank you thanks for well hopefully
i'll keep with the theme of having a
short report
um so members will recall that your last
meeting
you've set out the
strategic objectives of the council in
running leisure services in the future
uh that as you would expect was reported
to the active torridge shadow board
and discussed and one of the outcome or
the main outcome from that is a set of
overall strategic aims of active storage
they're set out in the report and
obviously one of the key factors uh
underlining that is the the active
tourist company
uh once and as you'd expect committed to
working in partnership with torridge to
deliver
this shared commitment
to chair the overall object strategic
aims of the company is set out on page
50
alongside um
how the company aims to do this so
they're set up at the bottom of page 50
and just over on top of page 51.
share the report is really for members
to note but happy to take any questions
and ask any questions should there be
any
okay anyone got any questions on
what's just been outlined
no okay thank you
item 14 on your agenda petitions there
are no petitions received
item 15 notices of motion which we have
three
that's from mexico
and myself
and i'll get on the country blenders in
a second professor ford yeah
um hopefully
this can be free
and i'm gonna be great but i want to
explain you know sadly to the recent
events i have to do this but i've seen
many other countries question the
ministry before
and i did rest assured those who senior
counselors have essentially got more
than i have to question myself to make
sure i wasn't being over the top and i
don't think i would
and
there's something important because
of the previous ideas a lot of this is
welding together and as you said chair
perhaps you can feel it's a waste of
time i don't i think best practices is
not always fine
so basically
keep this breathe and then we'll deal
with emotion
if evidence
is not earned or questioned is this
willful blindness or willful definite
please could i have and i would like i
did mention this view inside chief
so please do this in your convenience
but please i have a full transcript
of what guy incentive
gave to the standard hearing when she
was whispering in the cheer chair's ear
and not order also any members i have
seen that with
an officer and with a counsellor okay
i'm not a stupid person
[Music]
sorry about
that flip up there
but then if we can just get on with
another motion it makes common sense
with
proper
procedures
if you think about it i'm not about to
bring any of this up tonight if it's a
load that the officer i spoke to in the
curtis fashion and i always have to
democratic services who do a great job
and they've been so helpful to me
through difficult times and i thank tom
vanstone again yet again
for
is london his ear not taking sides but
london's here so let's just get on and
agree this is best practice all i'm
saying is not verbatim
just include what needs to be included
so it could always be a legal challenge
thank you
okay we've heard council reports uh
there's a motion second over there
that's the hawkins
what we have in front of us here tonight
is simply a statement there's no
we're not being asked to do anything as
a council we're not being asked to
acknowledge that or or to suggest that
or anything this is simply a statement
so to vote for vote against
what what are we doing are we voting for
to say we agree with that statement or
not i mean
i think that i think this knows emotion
is just completely
completely fake and isn't actually
asking the council to take a motion as
it were we're just putting forward a
statement
grass is green that's the statement
thanks chair thanks president i think
what comes to the ford is asking for is
the ability to speak to our democratic
services team after the draft minutes
have been presented in order that any
amendments members wish to make uh could
be made at that point um although up um
minutes not uh for are formally approved
at the next meeting at which time as we
did this evening members have the
opportunity uh to discuss and raise
questions and issues
at that point
thank you very much so so my
understanding is then council report is
asking the ability to do something which
you can already do is that correct
um
not not quite not quite enough that
sense then comes before asking for the
opportunity to speak to our democratic
services team in advance of the minutes
coming back to full council and change
them at that point rather than wait
until they come back to a council
meeting
that's our understanding to give out and
that's what you're voting on
and clearly it's not just coach reform
this would apply to any council
right
best practice
there's all this united in front of the
public
that's the question yeah um
when i was chair of this council uh i
thought it was the chairman
who signed off the draft minutes
uh if a councillor has any problem with
the minutes they need to see the
chairman surely not go back to
democratic services because
uh it's the chair of the council who's
responsible for signing them off and i
assume that was how it would work
but it's still the case i do get a draft
minute sent to me as i'm sure you did
for approval
that's it for did you like come back
originally i mean
i'm colorblind
anyway
i mean you know i'm an electrician i
think all the cables are different
colors
i'm actually you know we don't have a
better festive spirit
best practices is
therefore i'm questioning why
the officer was happy and i did say
go to youtube check this is the last
thing i would ask a member of this
council
to fabricate i just wanted on missions
that i considered where relevant to what
point i was making to be included
actually already happened so what i'm
questioning is it's not that about to do
this it's right there within two or
three hours
you could be writing an abrupt email and
a slap across the face which is all too
exciting
all the time let's do this
professionally when you clear it when
you win about all this nonsense serious
nonsense tonight
personal laws
thank you chair
uh yes i can i can understand council
force point but i think the simple thing
was if he were to take his query
through yourself and you could check
with democratic services but i think
that any counselor to have direct
contact with democratic services
not in this instance i stress but you
could have a counselor who is passionate
uh and upset over a minute
and it could then be construed as a
bullying issue you don't need that
because the counselling can bring it
through you you can inquire check with
youtube etc check the demographic
services and it would be
not put to bed or take it away perfectly
open it could
there is a clue in the title and i have
been even at cody level that's mr
mcgoffort to or the second leaflet this
right democratic services it means
democratic services okay thank you clue
in the name
right well it's been proposed has been
seconded online
yes it has been seconded so kind
what you're voting for as what the chief
executive said the ability for
any culture to go in and
talk to
the minute taker to clarify issues
before the minutes actually come back
is that correct
so it's been for books so we've taken a
move on it was regarded sorry yes
three
three four before the move against kai
shoppings
okay thank you and i'm on the extensions
you have to read them outside yes thank
you
the
uh was three four the notice of motion
21 against and five abstentions thank
you very much
until chair boy
do i know where i stand i am
only i needed that to start with happy
days i apologize no problem thank you
right now to notice the motion is from
my soul i will stands everywhere else
okay so
um
i'm sure we're all aware of the extreme
pressures currently being put on our
emergency services which affects uh the
communities and residents of torres i
therefore propose that torrance history
council rights to southwestern ambulance
service the mp for torridge and west
devon and the secretary of state for
help and social care to express our
concerns on the delay in response times
from 999 calls and the potential impact
this has on the health and well-being of
our residents now
i
i brought this motion before you because
on two occasions
quite recently i had occasion to die 999
um when discovering a young man that was
unconscious on pavement bleeding heavily
and despite 999 to the admin service all
i got was an automated message from
the
from their computer i couldn't get
through to a member of staff
at
surface ambulance service um so i was
forced to ring the place um i have to
say the police were absolutely fantastic
within four minutes i had three police
cars we attended did the first aid and
eventually they caught an anderson
public young man
taking the hospital the second occasion
was when
we were in town and came across an
elderly gentleman that collapsed
and once again
um 999 and no response now i did bring
this up with someone that i know that's
only recently retired as a paramedic um
and the
the
the situation that he outlined to me in
which is very similar to this
did not make a very good hearing and it
was you know it really did get me very
concerned now we've all seen the adverts
on the television where you've got you
know the elderly lady which is suffering
from uh from a stroke and how important
it is in the first few minutes of a
stroke victim well
you know we all know that we've we all
know you know people that
potentially have had a stroke in the
past
my worry is 999 isn't getting the
response that we all need and deserve
so hence my motion to right to southwest
uh ambulance service and the mp just
it's not a criticism directly of them
but clearly they are underfunded they
are under resourced there is an issue
somewhere that needs to address it
so i'd like to secondary for that okay
please
that's the first second of that
can we die
question question first yeah i'll second
this because i was talking to someone
just last week um
there they have an elderly relative um
lives in epidural
uh the lady fell over uh broke her leg
they phoned they came around luckily she
was on her own they came round they
found her they phoned
foreign ambulance
it turned up 12 and a half hours later
this was an elderly lady with a broken
knee
um absolutely astonishing
uh
i'm not sure where we will get with this
but i would support you wholeheartedly
actually because
um clearly something needs to be done
when we have situations like that and
saying
i
entirely support your notification could
i ask and it
would be for you it's not for me to to
do so but could i ask that you actually
put some local content into your into
the letter or whatever is sent by by
using local response times well i i
don't know what those are in comparison
to the national picture i think it would
have more impact if we were speaking
about or clearly demonstrating the
situation here by using local figures
of whatever our response times are
locally rather than just reinforcing the
national picture at the door thank you
that's a good idea councilor wrench
well
um
now we waited for
five hours
ambulance coming at all
in the end my wife took me
to aed herself
and good job she did actually
before
so you know if you want some
personal uh statements that go into this
letter i'll be pleased to help you um
thanks for brutality
and thank you you know i think somebody
something has to be done but not just at
this end where they're picking the pitch
pages up
we see now
ambulances waiting outside a e they
can't even get into anything
so you know
this
needs to be seriously looked at
thank you because
thank you i would just like to agree
with this whole heartedly and my son
saw a lady a very elderly lady fall over
and crack her head and her head was
bleeding and she was on the floor
and they ran me out for the ambulance my
son fought on the floor in the street
for 18 minutes with her holding her hand
because he was afraid of her in
consciousness and i i just think this is
totally unacceptable
well it seems i've touched on a raw
nerve here and it's clearly something
which is very close to all of our
thoughts so um
i'll take on broadcaster newton's
suggestion about adding some local
context to that but um okay it's been
proposed
thank you very much
clearly he's not here today i did take a
telephone call from him um before this
meeting and he
requested that his nose emotionally
deferred until the next meeting so i'll
propose from the chair that it is
deferred and the second offer
so christie all in favor of me
i'm actually anonymous again thank you
[Music]
okay items
16 and 17
this is exclusion of the public as the
remainder of the meeting remains exempt
confidential information so we need to
vote
i'll propose from the chair you're going
to part two because the news and
seconded
joe fans please in favor
thank you